foreign
Lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or licensed professional
[Music]
hello hello
okay dude so let's talk about it man
because first of all let's talk about
baby let's talk about you and me let's
talk about all the good things and the
bad things that that may be let's talk
about
let's talk about okay and I don't do
that so you're walking for that but um
that was free I am going to get you
added up because that's the thing when I
see myself in a smaller shirt because I
wear big [__] right because I'm I'm in
the trends but when you're doing well
because when you see this I'm gonna get
yarded right here and the and the shit's
gonna come down and it's going to look
absolutely ridiculous I'm gonna have to
hand out towels I'm gonna look you at it
I'm going to be at it huh right and then
I'm also you know what I'm also going to
do get a [__] cityscape like this
right here Escape yep get a [__]
cityscape I already got the 40. I got
the the elevator and the the Triceratops
and I'm gonna get you added right here
I'm probably just gonna get like a
street sign or something I don't know
what I'm gonna get but it's gonna be
insane what cityscape are you gonna get
oh well I have to pick I don't know send
in your submissions comment what
cityscape should I get right there
uh get uh Boulder Colorado right I don't
know about that that would be you know
but I should be like one of those
annoying guys that get the Silhouettes
of the trees on his [__] arms you
know what I mean they get the trees on
their arms and that's like I think
that's like the new barbed wire tattoo
trees yeah they get like silhouettes of
a forest
boo you know I don't know I'm just
saying I'm gonna think of when I think
of Boulder Colorado I think of uh my
joke over the shoulder Boulder holders
remember that we used to call bras no oh
they're wrong yeah don't swear first
five minutes of this the braziers but uh
you already did but I know I did so we
got to bleep that out uh but then over
the shoulder Boulder holders you know
what that is yeah I get it they're bras
it's a bra Brazier okay yeah but what
I'm saying is we had a little bit of a
tiff before we started
because I I was talking about how you
said you wanted to get the loop earrings
oh yeah no no no no no no no dangly
there's well you said loop earrings no
but okay well I didn't mean to say loop
earrings I'm getting the dangly cross
let's talk about what exactly happened
though because what exactly I don't
really remember honestly I'm gonna get
some loop earrings I said well you know
what you know I'm gonna get the dang
lacrosse and you said I said that first
I did and I said I said it way back when
and congratulations I don't care when
you what show you said I said I said in
Dad's walls I said that out in Grandpa
Bam's boss okay we gotta move that out
um uh should I say balls well you can if
you're talking about like a bunch of
balls
all I have in this world is
this time Halloween was on the weekend
so look dude
the Barry Bonds baby baby and George
Michael those two are my ear Idols I
should
dude I should be the one getting the
dangly earring by the way and I'll tell
you what look at the ear my ear so big
dude Jesus Christ could be on it that is
you got to put the photo here by the way
dude you've been putting the photos way
too late on the lifeline episodes man
we're talking about it and then you put
the photo too late it's Gotta Be when we
say the thing and you flash interesting
so we're not gonna fire Anthony but we
need to [__] make sure that that's
what he does dude I would fire I'll fire
him no we like the way he does the work
he does he's got a promising life ahead
of him you know what I mean I agree but
I would fire him just like that you
could fit Jesus Christ on the how I need
to get a [__] huge Crosshair that
thing looks matter when I'm walking it's
like pulling my ear dragging and and
major back problems yeah and and uh
Jesus Christ is on it or somebody that
looks like just get a guy like me who
looks like Jesus Christ yeah
no take wait take way too much time
uncomfortable and then when people say
look what the hell is that I say well
stop sinning and I won't have to do this
stuff
um but so I think that I'm gonna get
yattted up I'm gonna get the thing I'll
tell you why I should get the dangly
earring and that you it okay we can both
get it I'm getting it but what I'm
saying and you don't care if I get it
too I don't care about anything in the
whole world besides wow
okay but what I'm saying is Imagine Me
on stage doing my comedy rocking it bam
talk like this and it's swinging Bam Bam
Bam and it's swinging I'm yadded up I
get a dangly area with the cityscape and
everyone's like so this guy is somebody
that I want to be like this guy is
somebody that I see and I go I gotta buy
a ticket for this guy's show because of
how mysterious yadded up with a dang of
the earrings I think you would look bad
with a dangly earring I would look good
you don't look good with like [__]
good stuff on you that's why you look
good in that stupid shirt because that's
a bad shirt I have okay well it says New
Jersey so that's sacrilege I mean we're
from New Jersey I don't bow down to the
gods of New Jersey all right that's fine
but you're gonna say I look bad with
Stefan he's got the wimble no he's got
the gold band he's got the braces
for Focus you look bad in it
you know what I'm saying I look bad with
a hat I don't look bad with a dangly
earring and The Wimbledon and the
[__] and the gold and then the
bracelet for Focus why are you saying
Wimbledon
that's what the Rolex is oh really it's
the window is it green
it's got green in it oh yeah
um
all right but yeah so anyway I got the
bracelet on for focus okay that was the
most boring part of the whole thing you
said so why are you repeating that she
was like this is for Focus put it around
you when it breaks off that's when the
true Focus kicks in so I gotta be
focused but then when it breaks because
it'll break eventually it's been so
[__] long
it's annoying honestly but I'm focused
for now what happens when it breaks
that's when the focus really kicks into
overdrive I mean you hope what if it's
gone you don't think about it anymore
all right you know what I'll be focused
on where was my bracelet where's my
dangly earring
um so yeah dude um anyway uh I'm gonna
be in let's see well what's Sunday uh
was is it Jacksonville Lakeland
somewhere in Florida go to chrisley.com
what's the Sunday one
um because it'll be tonight do you know
uh and then I'm gonna be in next week
I'm gonna be in Sugarland Texas and San
Antonio Texas and then in a few weeks
I'll be in Rhode Island New Jersey I'm
sorry New York not New Jersey Rhode
Island New York and then
um [__] yeah Jacksonville dude that's
where I'll be Sunday night I believe
unless it's Saturday what's the 28th
oh [__] so you missed it dude I'm gonna
be in San Antonio Sugarland New Orleans
Providence Rhode Island New York New
York Chicago Illinois Kansas City
Springfield Tulsa Oklahoma go get
tickets just at chrysalia.com and uh
we're having a good time dude having a
good time having a good time
what's up you want advice
you want nobody to know about what's
going on in your life except one person
who gives you advice on the matter
mattelia.com for your troubles okay well
that's good and if you want to uh do a
uh a question which we love your
questions we love your videos watch
lifeline.com uh and you can get the
lifeline merch and get that spin
movement mentality adopt a spoon
movement mentality promote this move
mentality let people know you're bad
about it when it comes to the spin
movement mentality at lifelinemerch.com
thank you very much because I got new
merches coming soon we got numer to come
to it and look we're sorry but we have
to pay some bills right we have to raise
some bills by saying all that stuff so
leave a comment uh and let us know if me
or Matt should get the dangly earring or
if possible first of all if you do that
everyone is going to say I should get it
so everyone's always says that you're
like the better singer and all that
stuff I want you to understand something
that's a joke they're doing that to be
ironic no because you can't do [__] like
this and also likes the Josh Groban
thing that you do that wasn't even Josh
Groban but you do a Josh Groban thing I
do do that but I also go I put a sign up
right in the front window advertisement
right in the front window and all of a
sudden success coming out of the blue
you did Josh Groban at the end
remember that we're gonna have to bleep
that out no we don't we can save balls
you could say soccer balls grow my
soccer ball
um so yeah so that's from mushnick and
son with Little Shop of Horrors okay
loser
um dude I wanted when I was in high
school I wanted the [__] role of the
dentist so badly I know when you didn't
get it I felt bad I didn't get it
Trenton Reynolds got it that's [__]
Trenton runnels was good though but no
he wasn't he was going to be an actor he
was going places he you know he doesn't
even [__] anymore he's a Mormon
neither do I but he does yeah no he is a
Mormon and he's a great guy he's one of
my friends and he's a great artist by
the way what kind of art well not
singing dude but like he just painting
and [__] and he's really good he's
really he's really good okay like you
look at his stuff and you're like wow
that's really interesting it's not just
good it's interesting oh okay okay so
but when it comes to be your day hentes
fitting braces that would be my [__]
that is by far the best part in the
whole show
for people that don't know what we're
talking about Little Shop of Horrors the
dentist's role is the in the movie it's
Steve Martin yep who's hilarious yeah
that's the best part of the movie as
well yeah and generally in the
Broadway show it is like the scenes the
show stealing yeah yeah and it's also
you only have like two numbers and [__]
yeah that you got to do and you gotta
and you get to be like super like kind
of like Elvis if you want to be but also
have your own style on it look if I did
it too kind of like a rockabilly yes yes
dude if I was in it I'd shut the [__]
down
braces getting castrated in the very
beginning
[Applause]
somewhere somewhere above me I don't
know I know that my mama still loves me
all day Henderson
and a success oh yeah yeah yeah dude and
the success dude um I tried out for that
I didn't get it I was a freshman and it
sucks and Trenton just got it because he
was a junior it's fine like a harbor I
don't know I saw it and I was sad that
you didn't get it then I saw Trenton do
it I was like actually he's better than
my brother would have been you've been
holding that in for 25 years I didn't
know that I didn't want to say it to
hurt your feelings I wanted your
confidence to be high enough
but uh it's true Trenton's better
remember when you got so mad at me when
I said Charlie Plowman said I was a real
shooter and I was going places in in the
NBA and you got mad because you said you
wanted to be a basketball player and you
said why would you tell me that story
when you know I want to be a basketball
player
that's gotta be [__] horse oh no way
dude no absolutely I felt so bad you
were like why would you say that you
know I want to be in the NBA and in my
mind I'm just thinking you're not going
to the [__] NBA dude you really
thought that yeah dude
also because I was better at basketball
than you and I was 11. you were better
for your if you tried to play with the
try to play with the 14 year old you
wouldn't try to play with the big boys
yeah no dude I used to play with the big
boys remember New Jersey all the big
kids think you're a better athlete than
me and you know what I mean it's fine
you pitch and you're a good pitcher but
dude when it comes to like actually ass
kicking and trying to like you know if
you needed a getaway driver it would be
me but well you're better at martial
arts okay because you've done them
why do they do that can you explain for
people that aren't going to release the
key eye what is what well because it
starts the energy out and it makes your
[__] strike stronger earlier what's
kii a key eye is what that is oh oh
that's it like just regularly so yeah
okay
it seems like a waste of energy no it's
it's it's what you need it's what you
need it's the power you need yeah okay
but imagine me doing it when I'm yachted
up that would be crazy right and how
much would the [__] dangle
dude no you can't get into fights with
that [__] on your ear they just rip it
right out and win the fight right but if
I keep them at a distance with my key
eye power but I'm a peaceful man I never
get into fights that's why I should get
the dangly earrings anyway dude what I'm
trying to say is
um I should have gotten the part in a
Little Shop of Horrors and I would have
been I would have killed it you don't
know and that's not fair you didn't see
me in the full get up try and got the
full get up
and the hair I would have blue trunk out
of the water and
the song that bangs in that is the
Suddenly Seymour is standing
beside you it means there's no worries
wow the sweet understand
that song sucks ass what yeah yeah
that's [__] good one is feed me see
more no the good one is oh no it's good
but that's just like [__] it did The
Dark Horse one is the sadly Seymour
standing besides it sucks dude that's
like such a like a [__] show tune
lyrics but anyway dude I used to listen
to that well
it's good it's all good
oops I mean more that's the chorus part
but I was doing it
remember
hang on I just got a text
stop saying it's your neighbor all right
so uh let's go to the first one actually
we don't do this at my house I was
making a joke do it everyone was it was
just
all right hey Chris and Matt I have a
friend who um bragging thinks I'm their
minion and I tried to back away slowly
I'm trying to get through this really
quickly um but she was a little bit more
psychotic than I originally thought so I
didn't want to like rock the boat by
just you know doing anything harsh
she asked me to go get her belly button
pierced with her while she's five months
pregnant I don't know then she asked me
to ask a friend from high school
um if I
about her body that she had surgery done
to and I did said no to that too because
she can do that herself obviously that's
weird neither one of us talked to this
girl
um she got mad and she deleted me on her
own which is fine but I have confided in
her about my current relationship in the
past and I wonder
um if I need to approach people with
what she might do with that information
tell them you know be on the lookout
that's not you know whatever she might
say to you you know it's not me or
should I just like brush it off consider
these people smart enough to know the
difference thanks the 100 the latter you
definitely don't want to preempt yeah
some you don't want to preempt to sane
people
because some crazy person might
tell them things that are obviously
crazy like yeah everyone knows how to
filter out a crazy person it's fine
you're fine you're you're good don't
don't do that you'll create a problem
out of nothing yeah
um and then uh also so she was saying so
sorry help me out the minion thing this
other person thought she was their
minion
the friend thought the caller and that
girl that woman was her minion and a
minion is just somebody that does
everything that does their bidding okay
and and so now she's like I don't want
her to be in my life because she's being
crazy she were you listening I was yeah
I was listening literally to everyone
she denied
the her friend's request to like do
stuff for her that she didn't want to do
yes and then she deleted her as a friend
on social media right and now she's
worried that from things that you know
that she used to share with her that
she's just gonna start Start Spreading
the News yeah about it Start Spreading
the News and I know she doesn't want to
rock the boat sit down you rock and sit
down sit down Sit Down You're Rocking
The Boat Sit Down You're Rocking
that made me sweaty well I think it made
me but I'm I I it's amazing how much can
be musical it made me feel bad when you
did it that's why it made me say it you
know that's it you know this [__] on
your rock of the boat thing the song
yeah yeah Guys and Dolls yeah okay man
okay you were in that I was dude who
were you again everyone that nobody
wanted to be dude I was seven characters
all right Sit Down You're Rocking sit
down sit down Sit Down You're Rocking
The Boat sit on your Rockets
Down You're Rocking The Boat or you go
the ball it depends on what [__] part
you can also not do it at all that's the
best part if you're not in it this is
the best way to do it you can mouth it
so all right yeah I I uh yeah you don't
preemptively do anything don't I I look
I like the ice he's never preempt
anything I like for the record I like
the idea of bombing first but I don't
think it actually helps situations do
you like the idea of what bombing first
like hey guys this person's crazy no
boom it doesn't work it's not worth it
yeah it's just forget it she's crazy
she's gone be happy yep good riddance
yep there you go okay next
hi Chris and Matt I am currently
currently unauthorized sound podcast
episode nice and somebody called in
about
um not liking how people don't say bye
on the phone
and it made me think of how annoyed I
get when people brush their teeth in
movies and TV and then they just spit
and they never rinse their mouth and it
drives me crazy and I wonder if anybody
else notices it and like what's the deal
with that they don't do that they don't
do that but here's the thing and I think
I said this last time
and I I understand and I agree if people
are going to try to represent reality
then they should do things that people
really do but hey everybody let's
remember yes movies are not real yeah
right so we can take the shortcut and we
can take autistic license we don't rinse
our mouths out we don't say bye it's
okay that is true except for not
everybody's making a David Lynch movie A
lot of times the people are going to be
doing do you know what I mean right but
it's you know about it does bother me is
when people are like all right well
what's the number to that place it's 555
and then like the movie phone number
thing that's five so what would they do
instead
say other numbers but but then people
will be calling that number later but
there are other error codes that don't
exist
not every don't they do that every
possible combination of three numbers is
an area code I'll text it to your bike
do that
or that you know what it is I'll text it
to you so I don't have to say the 555
thing
yeah
I think that uh I don't so she's talking
about people brush their teeth with
toothpaste
well yeah and they're and they spit and
then they're just done brushing their
teeth yeah they spit and rinse their
toothbrush and put it back and then they
don't they don't do the work that
happens in movies yeah yeah
whoa I've never seen that yeah you
probably have you just have right right
and register it that's awful here's the
thing too most movies I would say most
movies try to emulate this sort of
realness that's why it's annoying I
agree but they shouldn't my problem is
that movies
try to emulate reality yes and movies
that try to emulate reality let me tell
you something none of them have been
remotely realistic no of course not so
don't even try make movies that are
absurd or like real life which is absurd
you it's a win-win for me if people
actually did the right thing yeah yeah I
wanted to lose loose because people are
like make it real right make a real
Winter's Bone oh it's so real it's so
gritty yeah nobody ever acted like that
in the history of the [__] world well
yeah Winter's Bone was took place a
while ago okay okay Jennifer Lawrence
first breakout movie yeah nominated
engine one okay relax for that she
didn't win no no oh I thought you won
did she win no no Dale Dickey won her
co-star oh really yeah
yeah but anyway uh Jennifer Lawrence is
a phenomenal actress I don't know if you
know that okay but she hasn't she's on
my show once and she said good job so
it's all good but um
yeah dude
um that is all good remember when we
remember when remember when um she was
dating our friend
oh my God yes and and they were he they
were he was working on Winter's Bone he
was shooting is that where they met yes
really dude and he was like
oh man he was like I don't know man I'm
dating this girl she's she's like the
lead of this movie it's called Winter's
Bone man
and he was working on Winters yeah and
he was like I don't know she's like my
girlfriend man I don't know everyone's
saying like she's doing real everyone
says she's so good magic dude she's such
a good actress man yeah he would get
really mad I think you're gonna get
nominee for an Oscar yeah he would get
really mad when she would like go to
Hollywood parties oh he would we were
like she's 19. I don't remember that
yeah one time he was complaining about
how like she was hanging out with Colin
Farrell and I was like she's 19. dude
and Colin was just like gorgeous ah
you're gorgeous ah you [__] [__]
gorgeous [__] you're [__] gorgeous
you know and he was like oh man
by your [__] gorgeous ah you're
gorgeous and he was at home like oh man
all right uh yeah dude um so anyway
about your question
um the I never seen that happen but
maybe maybe Matt maybe Matt saw it
happen I have seen it happen uh and I
agree that that is distracting and
stupid I have a hangnail
nobody cares okay next video okay nobody
cares
hey guys this episode is brought to you
by betterhelp and I'm glad to say this
because we need to take a break from the
uh podcast to talk about this
um look you know it's it's uh therapy is
becoming this thing that's kind of uh
being accepted finally and I feel really
good about this because I'm a big
proponent of therapy and better help is
the way to do therapy the safest easiest
most convenient affordable way uh when I
feel like I'm my best self I can do I
can operate at my highest level uh and
when you're at your best you can do
great things sometimes life gets you
bogged down and you may feel overwhelmed
or like you're not showing up the way
you want to and uh you know your work
your life your relationships can suffer
so working with a therapist can help you
get closer to the best version of
yourself when you feel empowered you're
more prepared to take on everything life
throws at you uh so if you're thinking
of giving therapy a try I strongly
suggest better help uh it's a great
option I have fans honestly come up to
me sometimes and say they tried it and
they're so thankful that they did it
um yeah if you're in a rut it's great uh
just fill out a brief questionnaire get
matched with a licensed therapist and
you can also switch therapists if you
don't like that one they want to help
you find a good match and there's no
extra charge for switching so if you
want to live a more empowered life
therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com Lifeline today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
help.com Lifeline get involved four NFL
teams two Conference Championship games
and only a few more shots to win big on
the playoffs with DraftKings Sportsbook
an official sports betting partner of
the NFL counting down to Super Bowl 57
new customers can bet just five dollars
and get 200 in free bets instantly what
not a new customer you can feel the
conference Championship Thrills with
stepped up same game parlays take your
shot at an even bigger NFL payout and
boost your winnings with each leg you
add up to 100 oh that's a crazy amount
of percent that's insane download the
DraftKings Sportsbook app and use code
Lifeline new customers can bet five
dollars on the NFL divisional round and
get 200 and free bets instantly only at
DraftKings Sportsbook with code Lifeline
minimum age and eligibility restrictions
apply see show notes for details look
man it is I am involved with drafts
Kings I am getting involved with
DraftKings if I am going to be betting
with DraftKings then you should be too
they got me involved in football dude I
love football and it look I'm a new
customer and I'm gonna be let me tell
you something about DraftKings though
what DraftKings I used to use all the
sites for betting now it's just
DraftKings oh really DraftKings
DraftKings DraftKings DraftKings
DraftKings okay saying it so much but uh
that's the deal though look Super Bowl
57 there's no other way to go uh you get
two hundred dollars in free Bets with a
five dollar bet and uh only a drop
skating sports book with code Lifeline
so go do it thank you
hey Chris and Matt uh love you guys so
thankful for the podcast oh thank you um
I wanted to ask you guys for some advice
okay I'm talking so British children's
hospital and it never fails that when I
walk into the room okay pause parents
will say something God bless great job
she is her whole face and her mouth is
talking British without the accent what
do you mean because she's like doing it
like this you know what I mean she's
talking like this that she's not the
British accent she's not doing with the
accent but imagine me just talking like
this but like I'm just I'm like no like
look at me like like talking like this
like I'm talking like this but like
she's doing it like a British I've never
encountered someone making less sense
than you are making only as only as
little sense all right okay then then
it's a lose I I'm I missed I know I get
what you're saying
British people don't talk don't look
like this when they're talking have you
seen um [__] uh Gilligan's Island
yeah actually
oh hang on the nurses here or are you my
nurse for today oh I got you so I would
like a spin move uh my daily
professional to give back to these
people
because I'm young and blonde does not
mean that I can't be a doctor that's
crazy yeah she's a doctor and we love
you for that and dude here's the [__]
God's work here's the thing if I went to
a hospital
and she showed up and was my doctor I
would be
thanking my lucky [__] star yeah
because you don't [__] hap because
most doctors yeah
are [__] dead inside
and don't even look you in the eye and
act like they've never had a good day in
their [__] life and she's Smiley and
nice yep the only thing that would be
better is if honestly if she was Indian
and then I would be all in but oh so
you're racist no no opposite Indians are
the best doctors yeah so you're racist
against
no I I am pro-indian yeah so thus you
are I'm not saying anyone else is bad
politician
dude
she this is what you do when there's a
are you the nurse you go like this he's
like no I'm the doctor oh good I'm gonna
you know what I'm actually prescribing
you this medication you give them some
pills and they say oh well I'm not here
because I'm sick no these these actually
these pills help with sexism
because you're sexist so because I'm a
doctor or you could go more hardcore and
and do that and the person says no I'm
not I'm not sick and she's and you say
oh no I know these you just take one and
it'll kill you just like that and then
the world will be a better place oh wow
dude get [__] disbarred or whatever
they call it suit yeah what do they call
it for the thing uh they take your
license away take your license away
there's gonna be a name for it but
anyway
mobile practice gonna get sued for my
practice Yeah she tried to kill me but
she should do it the British she's not
British actually if you listen to her
talk
um so the British nurse she's doctor and
she's American um so yeah dude I feel
like uh I feel like uh that's [__]
that sucks you're probably gonna have to
deal with that for a few more years
until you start looking a little bit
older maybe right
and the probably which sucks yeah but
female doctors well how old do you think
that lady is she looks like she's
probably my age she looks like she's
like in her well I think she might even
be younger than I think we saw her
walking on the street we'd probably be
like she started she looks like she's in
her early she's probably older she's
been through residency in med school and
all that I don't know dude I met a
doctor recently
she looked even younger than this woman
oh dude I had a doctor once I went in I
was sick I had a doctor yeah 12 she was
12 years old yeah yeah and it was
horrible the diagnosis of Horrors give
me two sugar cookies and then she [__]
all over the floor yeah yeah
uh that's a shame take two days come in
the morning and they were just frosted
in a
and then she had a heart with pink it
was like for Valentine's Day and then
she [__] all over the floor yeah she
well dookie Hauser
wow
[Music]
oh
dude
okay hell yeah dude dookie Howser why do
you listen to any other podcast
QVC a QVC why would you listen to any
podcast when you get here hilarity
advice brothership brothership
wow Brotherhood you get the
interconnectivity with the audience you
get vibrant colors look at this here
we've got Lifeline right here and this
is just
l-i-f-e-l-i-n-e that's L twice but we
have different letters e twice too and I
twice
brothership being so loud
Brotherhood
so what was the advice here for her oh
yeah the real advice I mean I guess you
gotta tread carefully because I don't
even remember such complaint what do you
mean no clue who the person was just
went with bits have no idea oh yeah she
was really sweet yeah how could you
forget her for a nurse anytime she walks
in a room yep which by the way I don't
think it's an age thing I think it's a
sexist thing it's both no it's
definitely both it's both it's both but
you're you're totally right but like if
she was 50 it would be a little
different yeah but no I agree it's
sexism but it's also ageism reverse ages
if she was Indian everyone be like I get
it okay stop saying stuff about Indian
people but um I think that
I think oftentimes in situations like
that like from India not if you just
keep Navajo retain yeah we know if we
retain because you're racism Prejudice
if you retain eye contact when you
correct someone just stake looking into
their eye for a little bit longer than
is I don't know like normal I think that
kind of thing goes a long enough way
where that also now that you're the
doctor and you're already in a position
of authority it will make the people
slink even more into themselves you
control the room even more
say yes without apology without
hesitancy and just stare into their eyes
and say yes I am the doctor right
and pause and keep eye contact or you
can be like you think I'm the nurse well
if if I was a nurse would I be able to
do this and then quickly do surgery on
somebody
just grab somebody from the hall no no
no no no no no no no no no no no on the
person no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no open heart surgery
no no please no no no
no no no no no no no you did it okay
you're a good doctor okay
okay
all right guys hello Matt and Chris
um my name is Gage so here's the
situation
what is his name Gage Gage g-a-g or cage
Gage his name's Gage Gage
hey I'm Gage yeah he's gauged again
he's gonna look because that's crazy
dude is Gage
I don't want anybody else
engaged to her Gage with you
he's a Mortal Kombat
Gage wins all right let's go Gage all
right guys hello Matt and Chris
um my name is Gage so here's the
situation I just got really high took
two Edibles and I was blasting Nirvana
and I went into a Planet Fitness Oh you
mean I had a panic attack oh you made it
come out to the car and so I can't drive
and I can't work out so I'm just kind of
chilling here and my first thought was
to send you guys in a video because I've
been wanting to do it for a while but
I've been too shy so uh [__]
uh I guess my question is
what do you do uh any advice for when
you feel very very sad for a very long
time uh like that's just been my life
lately okay and it just becomes like a
habit to just feel sad like how do you
just get out of a rut basically when
when like you get very comfortable inset
rut because that's how I felt lately
like I've just been so comfortable in my
sadness that I haven't been wanting to
improve in any way I don't know any
advice in that regard would be very
helpful thanks guys appreciate you
Jesus bye you break the cycle you
you're just High yeah no that's a big
part of it you know but one way to you
break the cycle because he's right he
said something interesting which is that
you get into a rut and then the rut gets
deeper and deeper and you become so
accustomed to it that you sort of like
lean back almost like it's a warm
blanket into the sadness because it's a
thing that you know you're familiar with
it and we always lean back into the
familiar things that's why people who
are traumatized
re-traumatize other people move forward
in life to traumatize other people
because it's what's familiar but what
what you're doing is pissing me off
because you're just sitting there
texting I forgot and that's traumatizing
me yeah yeah but um what I think it's it
sounds a lot simpler than it is because
obviously being in a rut and being sad
all the time is shitty and hard to you
know correct for but I think that
breaking the cycle is important but but
forcefully and with purpose break the
cycle for instance if you're sad every
day uh
day in day out take two Edibles and go
to Planet Fitness things like that will
help you get out of your rut it seems
like this might have done the trick he's
sitting there he's smiling he's laughing
and he's calling us well he's high yeah
but that is what I'm saying like [__]
you got to shake yourself up okay if
you're in a rut whether it's sadness or
just Melancholy whatever it is you gotta
like
shake the [__] up so that when you
resettle your perspective is even
slightly shifted because you can't just
trust yourself to be like okay I'm not
going to be sad right this is not how it
works we lean into whatever we are
familiar with and if we happen to be in
a
familiar with sadness period of our life
we're not going to just snap ourselves
out of that you gotta shake your [__] up
I mean it sounds like you're on the
right track with the two Edibles Planet
Fitness thing but you know I don't know
yeah I mean I would be careful careful
using substances to try and get out of
that situation but you know it's fine to
do that but uh once or twice and [__]
but uh yeah I think that uh well he's
doing things that are good going to
Planet Fitness working out exactly doing
things that help himself so that's good
but um he's overcoming his shyness by
calling into US yeah a bunch of good
things I mean look he's sad I understand
it's sad sometimes and that's good that
you at least know that and you're you're
you're you're you're identifying it
um but yeah what Matt said was right I
think that you know that's a good idea I
think that's a good idea yeah just
[__] shake your [__] up
shake your [__] change change the usual
when I'm sad day in day out I usually
find that I'm doing the same things over
and over and it's like I'm upset that
I'm sad but then I'm not doing anything
different any of the days and it and
once I realize that you change [__] up
you act a little bit different you do
something different one day then the
next day you do something else and the
next thing you know you're suddenly not
as a different person
suddenly you are feeling a little bit
better and all you need is that one
little rope that's dangling off the
cliff that you grab suddenly you're
pulling yourself into Robins pulling
yourself up pulling yourself up Suddenly
you're standing on the Mountaintop like
this and suddenly the world is yours and
you're not sad anymore oh you need your
rope look you get your rope all right
you gotta find the Rope okay if a little
bit dangling rope you pull it you pull
yourself up you pull yourself up you put
yourself up you get to the top of the
mountain where you want to be Top
Mountain and you gotta be screaming uh
now don't lose that hunger right because
the only person more hungry than the
wolf on the top is Wolf on the bottom
look at the top that's pretty good
that's what he would say okay so don't
lose that hunger just because you're on
the top okay
my face is too big go ahead my head
entirely too big
hey Chris hey Matt beautiful shot so
I've seen this guy started working at my
job recently no and and
more recently I've been having to
specifically work with him
and okay so we have to kind of you know
talk with each other during breaks and
stuff and during the job and he's got an
MTV cartoon he's not he has a bad social
awareness okay like he doesn't know how
to read the room why does he have like
people that have worked with him before
had said the same thing and now I'm
experiencing it I understand what they
mean like he just he'll talk about
himself or one topic for like beating It
To The Ground the same thing over and
over and you're like I get it like we're
it's been 20 minutes and it started with
me like asking him about a sandwich or
something I'm like we've said it all
like I don't know what else we could
possibly be talking about right now
about a sandwich but he just I don't
know he just has like poor awareness and
I'm bad with confrontation so I'll just
sit there and let it happen and I'll try
to change like change the subject but
then he'll then we'll just be talking
about that that thing for like 20
minutes
so
I'm kind of at this place where I'm like
I know I have to do something more I'm
not sure what because like I said I'm
bad with like I guess calling people out
on their ship so is there a way without
being a dick that I can tell him like
all right like okay that's we've talked
about that for a long time or you know
without completely dismissing him you
know like sometimes I'll get on my phone
like to purposely be like I'm not
interested and he'll fight this is Fight
Club keep talking and it's just
uh so I need to say something so just
anything that you guys come up with
would help thanks
it's you okay but hang on hey
it's you dude he said the same thing
nine times and it's [__] three and a
half minutes in this is a common theme
among people calling I'm bad at
confrontation but there's this thing
that I need to be confrontational for
you have your own [__] answer in your
in your inquiry
you need to be confrontational and
you're not going to be a dick the fear
is always like oh I don't want to be a
dick those things are not synonymous
confrontational is not the same thing as
rude or just like shitty or uncaring or
whatever you can be confrontational and
kind actually confrontational doesn't
necessarily imply a kind of rudeness
tell the guy
shut the [__] up well you've been saying
the same [__] thing rude over and
over again who the [__] would want to
listen to this did you ever think about
that okay that's where you're gonna get
fired and also these people well first
of all it's you but let's say it's not
you right these people will will will go
towards the weakest link okay so explain
that they will just they will find the
person they can talk to like this okay
they don't do it to me bro unless I let
them I go hey
what do you really do though come on I
go like this oh yo you've been talking
about that for way too long you do I do
yeah 100 I say I got the information and
you're saying the same thing right
that's what I do uh and it you I get not
everyone can do that not everyone back
when people do [__] like that I do
because I like to be confrontational and
I also like when people talk for so long
about certain things you like really
weird people boring weirdos yeah so
maybe you could give them advice for how
to enjoy it because if he's not going to
confront somebody if you're not going to
confront them you got to figure out a
way to enjoy it
so either confront them like I said not
as rude as the way I did it yeah or be
like him but you like really [__]
weird annoying people why don't you try
this this is what I do why don't you try
asking more questions
in depth about the thing that they're
talking about and see if you can pull
interesting things out of the boringness
because that's what I do if a guy's
gonna talk about sandwiches for an hour
I say so
what about the bread do you like and
they say oh no it's just good yeah but
what is it yeah don't accept good no
don't accept these [__] answers you
want to talk talk [__] you've
been talking an hour yeah so what what
what what are your top five favorite
types of cheese right monster okay so
now we got something to work with right
I don't know I don't normally think
about monster right so then when did you
first have a sandwich do you think oh my
mom used to make sandwiches and then we
get into the car by your mom what
happened with your childhood dude all of
a sudden it's an interesting [__]
thing maybe that maybe maybe maybe not
if not then we learned something about
your mom's friends maybe somehow with
your mom's friends who knows what the
[__] happened we learned that you like
the same show I liked when I was a kid
oh now we talk about the show and this
is interesting to me you like whose
company whose company
I think you should uh who's the boss
just get real with them and be like
you're like stunningly boring yeah you
know yeah miraculous you are stunningly
miraculously boring how is it what do
you like what what's going on when you
when you're talking to me but you have
to actually be interested don't be a
dick it is a dick thing to do but if
you're genuinely interested the dick
meter goes down significantly so if
you're like look I'm really genuinely
curious how are you this boring yeah how
do you think it's good to be saying what
you're saying yeah over and over again
I'm genuinely curious yeah now obviously
that's very rude but I'd like it I mean
you don't know if he would take that
rudely he might be like well if you
really want to know the truth and then
then we're cooking with gas yeah if
somebody told me you're being boring but
you're talking about this too much I go
like this
dude you need to know this
this is stuff that's not actually boring
it's for instance what if I'm talking
about like what I like about pants what
I like about pants you really know how
to be on me
um and so but like yeah and so I you uh
I think people don't know what they're
interested in this person is probably
not even interested in what the [__]
he's saying he's just talking to talk
like diary of the mouth you can't handle
that talk to me about what you're
interested in that's why I say when
you're asking the Deep questions about
the boringness then the deep [__] will
come out
and then we're both interested yeah
maybe that's riskier than just straight
confronting actually it's way less risky
confrontation can turn into fighting
oh he's not but I'm just saying it's
less risky okay all right next one
hey guys so huge fan here from Texas
it's such a soft voice okay so I am a
new mom I just had a baby boy 10 months
ago congrats and since then I have been
a stay-at-home mom which I love doing I
love being home with my son
um however he's almost one now and I've
been wanting to start my own business so
I've recently started a small candle
business
and I have all my product the website's
up and running now my only question is
what is the best way to advertise my
product without being too pushy or
annoying so what really gets your guys's
attention and makes you want to buy a
product when you see an ad and any
advice on just starting your own
business would be greatly appreciated
thank you guys thank you well photo
shoots I mean you got to get a [__]
bang and photo shoot right and your
Market is obviously to women no guys go
out there and buy candles unless they're
soft as [__] so you're gonna buy your
nice photo shoots with like pinks and
lavenders and do that [__] light them up
and make it nice and get an Instagram
page and then hashtag all the things
that Everyone likes like you know
candles uh Ambiance titties whatever the
[__] you want to do but people will get
the stuff you know what I mean no what
you really don't what you need to not do
and I need everybody to not do this
Jimbo's is this
don't try to be funny in your ad anymore
I'm going to put a moratorium on people
being funny in ads why it's never funny
well and that what that makes me do is
never buy the thing that's being sold to
me commercials are always bad though it
has honestly nothing to do with that
that's why directness is is is the best
thing right like this is a commercial no
bones about it yes that's what I'm
saying here to show you this thing photo
shoot because it's good right photo
shooting tagging the things that people
want like put the [__] photo shoot up
with the nice lavenders and the pink
[__] dimly lit you hashtag it candlelife
you know
moms wait what is Candlelight candle
life I don't know that'd be a hashtag
call a candlelife that's yeah but I'm
saying hashtag
Ambiance you know uh uh spit sharing the
stuff that people click what is that
what even is that
never mind the stuff that people clicked
you know and then oh look this nice
candle one in the middle of looking at
spit swapping like oh oh well actually
that's actually a nice photo shoot of a
candle maybe I'll get that she only
gonna advertise on PornHub no but that's
just the stuff that people
click you know I see what you're saying
like
um what do you call it uh uh uh ambiance
screwed up she should have said the name
of her company I'm gonna I'm gonna email
her and get him okay get the name and
get the candle life you said by mistake
because you definitely weren't trying to
be smart because I'm gonna give her a
free ad Candlelight is a thing and the
land of life is kind of a cool
tournament but that's my thing that I
created so now we're giving it to her
you [__] [__]
I want to have a candle take that like
you know like a nice dinner Candlelight
you should probably something like that
but Kendall she likely already has a
name for her company I'm not saying name
your company that I'm saying that's the
hashtag that's something
and unintentionally good that you gave
her you didn't need to I know you didn't
mean to I do mean to I do I do that
stuff good no but yeah
that people like right scented candle oh
BBW
by the way what is BBW big beautiful
woman oh really oh wow I didn't realize
it was so clean this is like a clean
term I I assumed it was something
disgusting yeah exactly yeah
BBC
yeah BBC is also a thing yeah that is
that too yeah oh I don't I don't know
what BBC is business
big black [__] yeah okay yeah
oh my God I said the magic words
fall big black car
why is that happening I don't know what
was that I don't know we have to bleep
it all out but
um
all right dude oh no he said it next one
[Applause]
he's still being the [__] the whole time
what up Chris Matt
um this is Andrew finish eating come
from Kansas City I'll be there in March
man yes [__]
first off uh
when I'm in like a conversation with
someone
I want to start a conversation I don't
want it to be boring I want to start it
right on like a Hot Topic it looks like
Sandra burner and
um
isn't it this is just one of the many
things I like come up with oh wow I was
thinking about when you drink when
you're super thirsty you go to drink
something the right way to drink it
for people usually just drink it and
chug it but that's not the right way oh
take a sip first get The Thirst quenched
and then drink another one a Big Gulp so
you can actually enjoy it and you're not
so focused on getting
your mouth undry oh you didn't want to
be boring huh my friend and my buddy's
just like
it's not that he doesn't agree but he
says
who cares like who cares if that's a
rule or not yeah yeah he says it's more
boring that I'm saying that rather than
if I'm talking about like say like I
don't know the weather or something
but I don't think that's how it should
work and I was just wondering
um
what you guys think about that like
wait is it where do I come up with
certain rules like that because they're
that is the right way like he's not
changing my mind but okay this guy I
don't know there's one of you guys talk
on that for peace thank you DJ quas dude
I want to know how many people he's
killed dude because he's definitely
killed at least three people why is he
talking like he doesn't have teeth when
he has teeth because he has was he
eating no also what was the question
is
the question was would what was this
question I don't want to be boring and
that's the thing I don't know boring I
want to talk about the things and so we
drink uh sip is hunting most people
think you just drink it but then instead
what I think you should do is drink a
little bit of a sip and then let it go
and then drink more of a sip and that's
when you taste it so to preface
I don't care about that and I'm just
like but these are things you should
care about and the weather talking about
the weather is better than that so what
do you guys saying about that
dude
what is he what what bro I think I think
his question was there should be are
there rules are there unspoken rules
there are I don't know what the [__] the
question is he's saying he he wants to
have conversations with new people this
is what I think it is okay
he wants to have he wants to talk about
stuff that's not just like hey what's up
what's the weather like I get things
like hey what's the best way to drink it
yeah I get that sure even go on Reddit
though and then his friend said that oh
this guy's on Reddit trust me you can't
force that though yeah no you can't be
like oh who cares about the weather
let's talk about the best ways to drink
drinks yeah how you doing man hey what's
up what's your name oh cool my name is
uh Kevin
um how when you drink a drink do you do
you probably just drink it straight up
yeah dude so I got this thing where you
take one small Sip and then you wait and
then you start drinking so anyway and
then guess what guess what you're never
gonna
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
dude what the [__] that might have been
the worst question we ever got who who
wrote also was that you who wrote that
or him no no he wrote it okay good well
I don't know well yeah maybe he's got a
self-awareness or something about this
guy does not have self-awareness so um
well that was great we love you we'll
see you in Kansas City for sure
chrisley.com I mean you know
Sandra Bernhard and Mick Jagger had a
baby and it's that guy Sandra Bernard
looks like me Jagger out of baby eats a
boy
um wow that was amazing bro thank you so
much for your call I wish there were
more calls like that for real I hate how
when people young I know but that's why
I don't look I don't look when people
yawn I look away because the sound is
enough I go like this
you want to go like this no no no no no
because they're not making me yawn just
because I've been looking dude cool
let's go another one
what's going on Chris and Matt my name's
Nico huge fan of the show hell yeah um
Chris been a baby since day one but I
actually have a question about
um a proposal so I'm thinking about
getting engaged to my girlfriend going
through the ring process now the whole
nine yards but um I want to know what's
a great way maybe a unique way to
propose to my girlfriend more New York
City there's obviously a lot of great
spots but there's also like companies
that charge like four or five thousand
dollars to do a proposal I mean wouldn't
make it then but not gonna do that but
um definitely want like pictures of it
and yeah and it just to be nice special
no restaurants or sporting events
anything like that but um would love to
hear your guys advice and hear what you
think um keep doing what you're doing
and life rips I think I know I have a
good idea I've always had this in mind
but I've never been able to
do it because it's like
uh
I've never been married and never asked
somebody to marry me if I did they would
surely say yes but yeah well I mean you
know so you just get on one knee and you
say
somebody stop me and then you say will
you marry me why would you do that I
like that movie The Mask
remember that but that's not romantic at
all okay fine both of this
smoking no that's that actually would be
the worst way to propose I can't think
of anything worse maybe [__] on the
Rings you say smoking and then you say
will you marry me I love you yeah and
but she doesn't hear the second part
because she left she's already driving
oh
okay well what's your [__] great idea
then
uh uh the fir when I was married first
the first time I was married I've been
married twice this is my second and in
tears this story then it's cool and it's
all good and it's fine
but uh I wanted to do it in a memorable
place and a memorable area
and a memorable time
so I went into the oh wait no oh my God
doesn't remember wow that isn't what I
did wow that was when I first told her I
loved her wow Jesus I thought that would
have mixed it up it was 20 years just
lie a little bit though so all right so
then
I went into the middle this is when I
first told her I loved her no this is
how you propose dude it isn't though I
don't want to lie
I I thought it was and then no this is
the first time I told her I love it oh
okay well you had a whole thing about
like yeah wow go okay go I went uh and
Dro we were driving I pulled over and in
the middle of um an intersection
and I walked out into the middle of the
intersection
and I said hey I wanted to do this for a
long time in a memorable place
um but I I I every building I picked I
was like in 20 [__] 30 years the
building probably would be a different
building or a different place or
demolished or whatever and I know this
intersection will probably be here for a
really long time so I wanted it to be
symbolic of this and I said and I love
you and people were honking and driving
by and so I'm gonna go move the [__] out
the way but didn't I thought that's how
you propose marriage no it isn't I
thought it was until I realized it
wasn't that so your big [__] line
well this was super [__] liar this
this you did 20 years away dude you did
propose that way okay in the headlights
you you pretended like something was
wrong with the car yes and that was
after the movie we saw a movie and we
pulled out of the drive the the driveway
and I didn't know how to do it
um and so I just pulled over and I was
like I don't know how to do this and I
showed her the ring in the um
in the uh in the headlights and then she
came out and she was crying and then we
and then she said yes
she came out she was crying because you
had abducted her and then she kept
running no no and uh and so yeah so that
was the I mixed it up but it was 20 I
have bad memory it was 20 years ago yeah
I have a worse memory but do you yeah
what's my name
is crimps no not crimps that's not even
a name
um so yeah I I don't here's the thing I
don't think you said no supporting
events and no restaurants and I get that
yeah I don't think that's ever really a
good idea maybe if you're both that kind
of person okay no but no I I don't think
so but you had to do what's good for you
um I think it's nice to just do a
romantic thing like
um
you know I get it if you don't want to
do it at home but something like a park
is great oh I gotta go or if you do a
picnic I got a good one so all week like
complain about a pain
on your lower back
oh my God my back's been killing me my
back's been killing me and then
like a few days in
you tell her ah you know what it might
even be like I don't know but you just
take a look and then you bend over and
pull your pants down a little bit and
you have the ring in your [__]
Matt what
I did not know that that's where you're
going and that's so bad what did you
think I was going to say you you said my
back hurts and you keep having to kneel
down to like do some back exercise until
she doesn't
suspect or expect yeah and then a week
later you do it and she's just like oh
he's gonna stretch his back and then you
pull out the ring and she's like and you
say my back wasn't hurt all along see we
came up with it that was a collaborative
event that came up with it no I had the
first half but your second half was
gated all of it and the ring is in your
[__] it would be you what do you say
it would be unique it'll be unique yeah
like your butt your butthole's a ring
holder yeah no I get it
just go down face down with your butt up
put it in there and wait for her to walk
in the door you'd be there all day then
your back really will hurt yeah yeah and
then and then and then when she comes in
when she walks in the room just be like
will you remember me yeah because your
face is up against the floor no do like
Ace Ventura with your butt cheeks but
then the ring will go Boop in your butt
no you're right oh no I lost it yeah
we're gonna have to wait four hours but
I have something to ask you
bring me the Xbox no but I think I think
as as long as it is personal to you and
her like something that yes both will
remember and cherish as a memory forever
like if you like both like Michael Buble
and you go to a Michael Buble concert
don't do it at the Michael Buble concert
but do it afterwards in a nice place
right or something like that yeah but
don't talk about Michael Buble yeah well
he's good I mean oh okay well then never
mind or the [__] guy Daniel
Bedingfield
I don't even know how that is
you know that song I mean what are the
lyrics I'm gonna get through this I'm
gonna get through this oh okay okay you
know I do know that yeah I'm getting it
I gotta get through there
all right we good yeah I think we're
good dude we really figured that one out
so we figured all them all out pretty
much so far thank you very much he says
that's last one well
um the [__] guy writes that's the
last one on the smallest phone the
smallest font dude I don't need my
contacts in
um so I fixed it now it says that's the
last one a little bigger so uh
uh yeah I'll see you soon San Antonio uh
Louisiana which is New Orleans and
Sugarland Texas I'll be there next week
and then I have Rhode Island New York
and also Chicago
Milwaukee Salt Lake City get your
tickets at chrisley.com and get your
merch at lifelinemerch.com
the one-on-ones with Matt Delia I'm at
delia.com get him save your life change
your life save your life okay and then
if you have any questions to submit to
us click the link in the description
below or just go straight to watch
lifeline.com yep there you go there you
go and uh that's it and subscribe to our
Channel thank you very much
Elvis
[Music]